you
so what we try to do is think of what
could we do nice for people like you in
addition to thanking and thanking you
which we do and one of the things we
like to do is to share some of the
intellectual capital that exists around
the school and I'm particularly pleased
tonight to introduce two people that are
very special to our school they are both
alums I don't think we've ever had a
program like this where we could bring
two alumni together and two such
distinguished alums and it's a probably
the only pair like this in American
higher education a father-daughter team
so let me introduce the team I'll start
with the daughter on my immediate left
Jennifer rocker who's a graduate of our
ph.d program in 1995 she went from here
to UCLA to make a reputation and do lots
of great stuff and we were fortunate to
attract her back here to join our
faculty she came I think about the same
time I did in 1999 so she's been here
ten years now with us off and on and she
is a real star and leader at the school
she's a professor of marketing a chaired
professor her expertise lies in the
psychology of time money and happiness
something none of us have quite enough
of
how's that for an area to probe in depth
the psychology of time money and
happiness Jennifer is a fantastic member
of our faculty she's also been a faculty
member at the Haas School over at
Berkeley but we're really pleased that
her focal point now is at the Stanford
Business School
she's a stellar researcher and has had
lots and lots of publications and
recognition in her field of marketing
she's a super teacher and she has won
the MBA teaching award which is
something very few faculty win and those
of you who were MBAs here which is most
of you know this is a pretty important
recognition voted by the students and
she's also a real leader in the school
she was a member of the group that came
forward with a new curriculum that we're
now into our second year of
implementation and she's a member now
the Dean search committee looking for a
new Dean which will take us to even
better and higher places so that's
Jennifer rocker and on her left is David
Acker dave was a PhD graduate also of
the Stanford Business School in 1969 a
little bit earlier and dave is also in
marketing how is this father/daughter
marketing wizards
his work focuses on brands and brand
building and on brand portfolio strategy
and managing marketing across silos
he's probably got even more books and
publications than Jennifer but then he
said a lot longer to work at it he's got
I think 14 books the latest one is on
spanning silos if you haven't seen it
and everybody knows about silos and the
need to span them Dave was a longtime
member of the faculty at the business
school at Berkeley he's now an emeritus
member of the faculty but in addition he
has a consulting firm that he's the vice
chairman of called profit which does a
lot of consulting on marketing and brand
strategy and related activities in the
corporate world so we're really
fortunate
have dueling professors in conversation
I don't know how this is gonna work but
I'm turning it over to Jennifer and Dave
Walker please welcome thank you it's
nice to be here I went to school with
Bob in fact I tutored him in marketing
so he could pass his generals eye I want
you to know I'm good I'm good but you
know there was a time in which I was the
featured speaker not the warm-up and and
there was the time when people called me
to ask me to speak to their group
without saying at the outset you know we
tried Jennifer but he was she wasn't
available
let me just yeah Bob introduced Jennifer
she's she's really terrific she's a
wonderful person and she's won three
teaching awards actually she's uh and in
her classes are oversubscribed her class
just finished today and she had these
groups to applying social technology and
one group was was interested in in
donors getting donor organ donors and in
one month they got 45,000 people to view
their website which was organ donate is
sexy and they got 88 people to donate
organs and that was just one of her
groups and in just today's class and
she's an incredible researcher you know
twenty eight articles three best paper
Awards and you could argue she's
actually created four new fields of a
search for her field it's really quiet
quite remarkable and I know what you're
thinking you're thinking that I'm
responsible especially for her fast
start that it was my influence and
mentoring and so on that's not true
actually actually when she started out
she had to to kind of things top in her
mind one was to try to avoid a period
young so she used to wear glasses and
put her hair up and and everything so
she would get respect and the second
thing she was she wanted to not be
associated with me because I was
perceived as managerial and she wanted
to be perceived as academic and so so
the influence was as you might expect my
charge is to give you an overview of my
research a few headlines and to kind of
relate that to Jennifer and give you
kind of a little bit of an insight into
Jennifer so that's what I'm gonna do my
field in the last 20 years is focused on
brand strategy I started off doing
research on brand extensions and and
then I did some research relating brand
equity to stop return turns out that
brand equity has nearly as much impact
on stock return as does earnings and
then I did some work on emotional
benefits
I studied the emotion of warmth and we
showed how to create warmth and and what
warmth can also do to the ROI of the
business and then in the late 80s brand
equity started to emerge and I wrote my
first book called managing brand equity
my first brand book and I kind of
defined brand equity and and just to
define buying equity as an asset
completely changed marketing I mean it
wasn't my book but it was the fact that
this construct emerged and so now all of
a sudden marketing is strategic instead
of tactical it's the job of the CEO and
not the advertising manager it's it's
it's it changes the way you look at
marketing changes the way you fund brand
building activities and to also I
defined it as including the customer
base and the loyalty of the customer
base and that also really influenced the
way people viewed marketing and brand
marketing and then five years later I
wrote a book building strong brands that
I show people how to creat brand equity
and the heart of the book was the
concept that a brand is more than a
three-word phrase it's actually
multi-dimensional as usually eight to
twelve dimensions and among these
dimensions are brand personality very
dimensions like being energetic and
being approachable and they are also
organizational associations like concern
for consumer being innovative and which
are properties of the organization and
not necessarily the product and then you
it also suggested that you create three
or four of these elements as the most
important and use them to drive your
marketing program the third book I wrote
in 2001
candy gave you the the generation 2 of
the brand identity model and it also
talked about how do you go about
building your brand how do you translate
the brand identity into brand building
programs and one suggestion for example
was you look at role models both inside
the company and outside the company if
you want to be perceived as innovative
you look at it get people or programs
that are innovative and you look outside
your company to other companies that
have pulled it off and you and you say
how do they do it and and see if you can
get some ideas and the fourth book was
brand portfolio strategy and that
recognized the fact that most brands
have or most companies have multiple
brands they have family of a brands or
portfolio brands and they're usually a
mess and in fact sometimes some
companies it's so messy that they're
paralyzed they can't even come up with a
new product because they they don't know
what to call it
the brands are a mess and so what this
book did is try to sort that out and
suggest that each plan should have a
role and these brands as a family should
combine to create clarity synergy and
leverage and in in the book I suggest to
the concept of a branded energizer it
turns out we know from recent research
that the most important element of a
brand today is not differentiation it's
not relevance its energy it's really
quite extraordinary the brands that lack
energy are going downhill and and this
is true across the board and it's been
true for eight or nine years the brand
is what energy are a whole different
story
and it's really empowered to generate
energy I mean not everybody can be a
Nintendo or an apple and if you make
frankfurters or if you're in the
insurance business it's a little hard to
get people excited and I say that
because my good friend is the head of an
insurance company is sitting in the
second row but in that case my advice is
to find something with energy and brand
it and attach your brand to it like the
Avon Walk for breast cancer for example
that's a brand that's now 16 years old
gives avon enormous energy they've
raised incidentally five hundred and
sixty million dollars for cancer it's so
it's not just talk but but anyway that's
a suggestion for gaining energy you know
I have to say that when Jennifer his
dissertation came out she developed a
scale for brand personality a scale that
revitalized that whole area and I
thought to myself man she is following
in my footsteps and she very patiently
explained to me you're a brand
strategist you deal in brand personality
I am neither him of an experimental
psychologist I deal in the self
expressive characteristics of consumers
so careful to provide some distance but
then 2002 which was now five years after
a thesis no seven years she taught a
course in brand strategy at Stanford and
she chose my book as a text I didn't
call it brand strategy I'm just
Brande planning of course of course but
if she chose a book that was 11 years
old
managing brand equity I said Jennifer
why and she said well you know I I
haven't read any of those books and I
was under time pressure I just picked
one but he said on my to-do list is to
read those books
another thing I've done is is write a
book on marketing strategy really
business strategy I wrote this in the
early 80s it's known as ninth edition so
I'm continually - continuing to write it
and the headline of that book is that
you need to de-emphasize short term
financials and you steady have to focus
on building assets and competencies and
you have to know how to manage your
brand globally managing across markets
so I thought I heard Jennifer's second
article which was very influential was
on global management I thought so I
thought well haha she is taking my
advice to go into global management area
and she said very patiently that you're
a global marketing strategist that deals
and things like global brand management
I on the other hand I'm an experimental
psychologist I deal in cross-cultural
consumer behavior so again little effort
at separation my latest book came out
last October is called spanning silos
the new CMO imperative and what I
thought of found in working with
executives and companies not on brand
and especially trying to help them
manage their brand globally is that
there's some some really serious silos
and there's product there's country
silos and regional silos but there's
also product silos I mean Toshiba must
have 30 or 40 different product
divisions each with their own marketing
department and in addition to that
there's functional silos within
marketing we have sponsorship we have
advertising we have PR we have
Internet and and call centers and on and
on
and and these silos basically you know
very comfortable being isolated from
each other they regard the other silos
as competitors and and that's really
served American business well for almost
a hundred years since 1922 and Alfred
Sloan started this decentralization
organizational structure but it just
doesn't work anymore I mean it just
doesn't because products brands
customers marketing they span silos and
you just can't have these autonomous
silos you know among other things the
brand coordination is a complete mess
because all these silos are taking the
brand in in their own direction and
there's as a result the brand gets
confused not only in the marketplace but
also internally so people in the
organization really doesn't don't know
what the brand stands for and then they
can't obviously deliver you know Pro
each of these silos don't have enough
budget to really engage in effective
marketing because effective marketing
these days requires scale you know a
major sponsorship for example even a
major advertising campaign requires
scale and so you have to find a way to
to work across silos to develop
marketing programs and also in offerings
customers don't want to buy components
anymore they want to buy systems so IBM
for example has to find a way to get
these silos to work together to provide
systems for instances for customers you
know Walmart wants to deal with Procter
and Gamble they don't want to deal with
with 30 divisions of Procter & Gamble
they want one entity to deal with all
their logistics all their ordering all
their promotions and so on so you've got
to you know be able to span silo
in order to deal with offerings that are
demanded by the marketplace and resource
allocation with independent silos is
really dysfunctional and of course these
days you know that kind of waste just
can't be tolerated
but what happens is the the establish
silos that have income coming in get to
spend that income and therefore they get
the resources and the new emerging silos
don't you know at IBM for example that
went on for years and years every year
at the beginning of the year they would
say we're gonna allocate money and fun
the new emerging silos in the emerging
markets and during the course of the
year the established silos would suck
them the investment back to them because
they had a program they were in New York
and and so on and they got the money so
finally IBM last year set up a
completely separate organization for the
emerging market so it's headquartered in
Shanghai and now they're gonna get the
budget and they're going to keep it and
they're gonna invest it like they should
but it's such a dramatic organizational
you know change in order to make that
happen
so I talked to over 40 CMOS of major
companies throughout the world and I
asked them you know what are the
problems with uh silos and what are you
doing that's working and in the book
talks about a couple of dozen things but
a couple of the headlines are that
centralization and standardization
should not be the goal of the CMO in the
central marketing group as it often is
and because what happens is it's it it
leads to start of too ambitious a
program and and you at least a flameout
I mean the average CMOS tenure is 23
months that compares to over five years
for a CEO so so you've put a lot of
stress on the organization a lot of
expectations and pressure if you try to
do too much
so the goal should be rather to address
these problems to try to create brand
coordination programs offerings and
resource allocation to deal with those
problems and anything you can do to
replace competition and isolation with
cooperation and communication will
advance those things so that should be
your goal and it might involve
centralization it might involve some
standardization but that shouldn't be
the goal the second at CMO can go a long
way toward that goal by acting as a
facilitator or a consultant or a service
provider so for example Nestle has a
center of excellence in around Hispanics
and around mom and kids and so on which
a lot of their product silos have find
relevant so it's a vehicle and then they
have a steering committee that includes
people from the silos and it's a vehicle
to really get together to start
communicating start to relate to each
other on a common issue again is not
threatening and it moves the ball
consultant you know visa for example to
act as a consultant to all their country
silos that have brand tracking data so
they help them interpret this data and
they help them you know respond to the
problems that it detects and a service
provider you know at BP the central
marketing group does segmentation
studies and they've been so good and so
effective that the silos are standing in
line to try to get them to do a
segmentation for study for them so
that's a second headline the third is
you really need to leverage silo ideas I
mean these days we've got to find a way
to do more with less and that involves
really good marketing ideas and one way
to get them is to let the silos work for
you let them come up with ideas then
recognize them and roll them out to the
they're silos and you know if you the
adora game from south america Pantene's
here so healthier chines that came from
taiwan mcdonald's loving that came from
germany but at each case they had the
presence of mind to recognize that
excellence and immediately test and roll
it out to other silos so just one a
couple more things about jennifer before
i turn the thing over you know you ask
yourself why is she so successful and
one eight reason is she multitasks she's
always multitasking and everybody in the
family can to know if they're talking to
her in the telephone if she's away from
her computer you're getting about 90
percent of her if she's on the computer
just reading email you're getting about
sixty percent and if she's writing email
you're getting thirty percent and you
you it's it's you know quite easy to
tell which is which
and what else was I gonna say about
anybody been at Jennifer's class if your
attention wanders in your in your class
she'll call on you right if you get a
cell phone call whoever called becomes
part of the class discussion it is so
embarrassing
and so she's very helpful that way
she's keeps you on your toes well if you
want to know more about Jennifer YouTube
you can read I wrote a book on my story
so far and Jennifer is featured in the
book and you can read more the the one
on the left you see her first and last
effort at yard work
in the middle top you see her first and
last effort to take a hike in the
wilderness and on the right top you see
you know that there are no Flair for
clothes and dressing and fashion started
really early so I'll turn it over to
Jennifer she's a wonderful person and
dissin to being so talented
and she's my best friend so it's so nice
to be here thank you for creating this
and for inviting us both here
my dad is quite modest he lets see oops
okay let someone else do that so I don't
know if you remember this but so I let
me just give me a little context of all
the presentations getting set up so I
grew up in this wonderful household you
know with two sisters and I kind of knew
it early age that I wanted to do
something interesting with my career and
I wanted to have a great family I knew I
wanted to have kids and I wanted to be
there for them and I wanted to have this
interesting career and I just I sort of
didn't know exactly how that was gonna
happen because it's very hard to find
role models who can do both well so as I
was growing up I noticed that my dad
would work up in his office creating all
sorts of really interesting research and
then periodically around 1 o'clock 2
o'clock 3 o'clock would come down for a
snack and and so he would kind of come
down have a little brownie go back up
and come back down say you wanna play a
little tennis let's go a little clay a
little tennis I takes out to play tennis
and then go back up to his office and
get some more research done you know 5
o'clock he comes over and he sort of has
another snack and then he's what about
you know scheming tomorrow and and I of
course was the oldest daughter so I said
no I've got too much work to do but my
two other sisters said yeah sign me up
that's embarrassing so as I grow older
and older trying to figure out what
career I'm gonna take on you know my dad
kept saying like have you
and we thought about being an academic
and I thought no that's that's insanity
I would never do that and so I worked
for IBM IBM for a little while and that
didn't that didn't work out
you know as well as I would have hoped I
worked far too intensely and so at the
end of that summer my dad said have you
thought about being an academic and I
said that's insanity I'm not gonna do
that so I I went off and I worked in
advertising for a little while and I
remember my first interview my boss at
the time it said you know how do you
foresee yourself working and I said you
know uh in cafes actually do you mind if
I do a little work out of cafes I don't
know why he hired me but somehow he
thought that was good so that didn't
work out great and dad kept saying what
about academic I mean I had this mental
image of him coming down at 1 o'clock 2
o'clock 3 o'clock
playing tennis with us and stuff and
looking at he thrived and I finally said
you know this this is a good job this is
I don't know what I was beating myself
up and I have to tell you I feel so
blessed answered is a tremendous
tremendous place and I feel so fortunate
to be here knowing you and and and
speaking a little bit first of all
you're probably asking yourself what
have you been doing lately your your
father has been producing books on every
two to three year basis and what have
you been producing and so this is my
esoteric paper number one that no one's
read
that's the esoteric paper number two
which you know only ten eleven people
have read the third and then the fourth
yeah so you're probably wondering
wondering you know why so slow you know
there's no book covers up there there's
just esoteric papers up there so I'd
like to defend myself for a second and
and sort of mention why I am so slow so
the first the first reason is taya Sloan
she's my three-year-old daughter we've
been working on makeup application so
how to do it best practices role models
the second is Devin Devin Smith we've
been working on things like
recycle writing he's you know six years
old so I figure introduce it at an early
age Pokemon collecting a karate kid'
training by Cooper Smith and so you know
that's that's been part of the problem I
would say now in Dad's defense he's
actually helped he's this is him playing
against the Pokemon cartoon character my
husband at a recent birthday party so
you're you're probably thinking to
yourself you know what are you gonna
talk about since you have not produced
very much at all and I talked to my
father about this I said you know what
should I which I do and he said Jennifer
try to dig deep into her Arsenal
research don't you have anything that
just isn't completely esoteric remember
back in 1997 he wrote a paper that I had
some implications that people find
interesting why don't you talk about
that and so we had this internal debate
I thought you know I should just talk
about a little bit of my you know
different research and he said no find
one thing that has some relevance
somewhere and just honing on that focus
so what I'd like to do instead is ignore
that advice and then instead talk about
what I wanted to talk about which is
multiple papers that I find interesting
but I'm gonna do so in a way that
hopefully will have some appeal I'm
gonna do it in a way that emulates sort
of how my dad summarizes my research so
as to try and make it sound more
interesting so I'm going to turn you
know language into his and and unpackage
it that way interesting finding number
two in the first esoteric paper brands
have personality who knew now I just
have to tell you whenever my dad finds
something really boring but wants to get
other people engaged he'll throw in that
phrase who knew and and so you're
probably thinking I knew that I knew
that that was something that I knew but
but the way he says it it makes you
think well maybe I did not know that
it's not it's not clear I knew that I
thought I did before he said who knew
but now I did not know that I knew that
so
so a little tip this will be colored
with little tips for you to take home to
your own kids so let me tell you a
little bit about what he found
interesting in the first esoteric paper
published in 1997 as I mentioned to you
I worked in advertising for a while and
I found individuals within that industry
to be fascinated by the self expressive
role of brands or the emotional role of
brands this idea that more people tattoo
harly on a part of their body than any
other brand in the world is not because
harley has a good functional benefit
right it's not because it's quiet it's
not quiet it's not because you know it
gets good gas mileage yeah I do not know
if it has good gas mileage but but it
says something about you right it says
something about you and the woman when
you drive it you feel a certain way and
yet even though all of these advertising
agencies we're so intrigued by this
notion of understanding the personality
with a brand no one had a systematic or
rigorous way of measuring it right so
they would you know have all the
managers throw in random personality
traits that they thought were
interesting trendy or exciting or cool
or whatever it was done yeah not
systematically and on an ad-hoc basis so
what we did in this research born at
Stanford was to systematically cover the
world of traits we started with over
3,000 personality traits we had
individuals rate over 40 different
products brands services nonprofit and
for-profit both on what was reduced down
to 300 traits and through a factor
analytic procedure we know that list of
300 traits down to 100 and then 242
traits that represented five families of
traits if you will five schemas that
consumers at least American consumers
used to think about brands so that list
was relatively robust it wasn't owned by
one brand like Levi's it was
generalizable across categories and the
five families of traits were called
sincerity these are the brands that
garner trust there is excitement these
are brands I get you excited they're the
Energizer's that my father
was talking about their exciting cool
trendy young imaginative hip they have
got energy the third family of traits by
the way the first to explain 50% of the
variance in the personality space that
they're both very important competence
is credible intelligent hard-working
successful leader confident a lot of the
hardware and software spaces claim they
own competence what they don't own
necessarily as a secondary point of
differentiation that that pulls them
apart from other hardware and software
companies the third dimension is called
sophistication which is upper-class
charming feminine smooth
it's like brands like Lexus and the
fifth is ruggedness which is the Harley
Davidsons of the world it's rough and
masculine and strong tough outdoorsy so
now we have five families of traits that
can be used to sort of systematically
track brands over time and against other
competitors and we find through
regression and other types of
statistical means that if you look at
the relationship between market share
and these five family families of traits
first of all 75% of the variants marry
market share is explained and across
categories the single dimension that has
the highest correlation the most
significant beta coefficient with market
share is sincerity and that's even more
important these days where trust and
authenticity believe to be owned by an
organization has greater sway than
anything else so these companies that
garner trust effectively are incredibly
important to watch interesting finding -
but those bundles and personality
personalities are my dad would say
aren't the same across cultures
peacefulness is important in Japan and
Spain passion is who knew so you
probably did but the way he said it so
if you replicate this entire process in
a bottom-up emic based way in Japan
starting with over a thousand indigenous
Japanese traits using global and local
brands in Japan and again from a
bottom-up process reveal the families of
traits that exist in their minds five
pop up again which probably resonates
with some
you there's something very special about
that number seven plus or minus two in
terms of cognitive structure and but
ruggedness disappears it doesn't exist
as much in Japanese consumers Minds
peacefulness pops up which is peaceful
mild calm harmonious naive mild-mannered
it's almost like a Geisha girl if you
will
ruggedness doesn't exist that John Wayne
notion of strong rugged masculine
doesn't doesn't pop up and it it raises
really interesting questions if you are
Nike Harley or Levi's or Marlboro and in
fact in those cultures where ruggedness
doesn't exist nearly to the degree that
it does in North American countries
these these these companies really just
come across as one thing which is
American so you're either gonna have to
educate other cultures about what
ruggedness means which takes a lot of
time and money or you and you you
position yourself around excitement or
some other dimension that Nike might own
but which has cross-cultural
generalizability in Spain when we do
this bottom-up email-based process
competence and sophistication collapse
as a structure and my Spanish colleague
at the time when I was trying to explain
you know what's going on why would you
know hardworking and successful leader
competent type of set of trades collapse
with sophisticated glamorous
good-looking and she said you know only
in America would your presidents be so
poorly dressed that would never happen
in Spain those two things intermingle
leaders look good
peacefulness also arose another
collectivist culture like Spain and
passion intensity and mystical Bohemia
and spiritual intents popped up
interesting finding three these
personalities guide the consumer brand
relationships and relationships are
important trust me that's another thing
dad says to kind of get you engaged you
know you're starting to like nod off and
he'll go nuts
really trust trust me and that makes you
sort of engage let me give you a glimpse
into the research that went into this
insight this is we're done with Susan
Fournier out of Brazil and I and what we
did in one particular study is start to
track you know most most companies try
to reach this area of emotional rewards
and having an intense and strong
relationship so if you look at the
interpersonal relationships marriage
partner best friends close friends are
up on the right-hand quadrant and what's
what's over on the left is
compartmentalized friendships childhood
buddies drinking buddies down here's
casual acquaintances master/slave
relationship versus because yeah you're
probably looking at the more girl
Cablevision and Microsoft Microsoft no
matter what they do no matter how much
good they would do people will just be
pissed off thinking you know this is a
map if I could get out of this
relationship I would it's it's an
incredibly I feel so bad too because the
positive that Microsoft has done is
really quite it just makes you realize
first of all there's a couple things in
the interpersonal relationship world
people's feelings about an individual
are oftentimes assessed and understood
within the first 10 seconds of meeting
that individual so you meet them
incorrectly and you might also just give
up like it's all over it's ten seconds
and that gives you that sort of window
into the nature of the relationship and
the way to think about a relationship
with a brand and the consumer or even
within consumers is very much like you
know I have one personality and Andrei
might have another personality and we
might be very nice people but there is
something about the personality of that
relationship that just doesn't work and
he could try and I could try and it is
not going to work personalities are very
robust right and and and and they don't
really change and so if you are a brand
or a consumer or an individual I
understand the personality of that
relationship intuitively and also build
on it if you look at Starbucks here's
this piece very different relationships
that the way you go into Starbucks and
it's a long line and you think there's a
new barista here and I am going to go to
the Starbucks next door
I'm not gonna wait in this long line at
Pete's you go and there's a long line
and you say like it's a good barista
this is gonna be a great cappuccino I'm
just gonna settle in long line and hang
out and talk to these people in the line
so the basic nature of the relationship
is fundamentally different
the next insight to think before you
promise trust we did one little
experiment this was one where we
manipulated two brands this was called
there was a photography service brand we
called captura and we made the same
brand very sincere and we made the other
brand very exciting so both called
captura but one was sincere at promised
trust the slogan was life is too
meaningful to let you pass it by work
with us the exciting condition so you
were in the sincere condition these guys
are in the exciting condition we said
capture because life is too exciting to
let you pass it by and everything about
it was very hip and cool and fun so two
same brands promise the same thing but
the language with which we spoke nurture
trust versus excitement we we had people
interact with the capture over the
course of two months and we created four
conditions on our experiment so you guys
interact with capture the sincere brand
over the course of two months and you
came to our website to learn about us
etc now everything went fine for you
guys but for a half of you in two weeks
into the relationship by the way we
Federal Express to all disposable
cameras two weeks into the relationship
we let you know that after we developed
all of your online photos and put them
on just like Shutterfly or easy you know
easy share Kodak etc we told half of you
we accidentally lost or online photos to
do is P problem we're so sorry did the
same thing with you guys everything was
fine you're in the exciting group
everything went fine for two months for
you we said oh we're so sorry we lost
our online photos you know what we
really didn't mean to really apologize
two days later we came back to you guys
and said we work very hard to restore
your online photos please come back we
apologize same thing with you guys and
we tracked relationship strength over
the course of those two
to two months first set of findings so
the dark side of trust for you you had
originally you know kind of intriguing
ideas about the relationship strength
with this capture bran you started off
at four unit up around six so by the end
of the two months you were engaged you
were loyal you were gonna tell friends
about it you've trusted the brand in
contrast you who also started engaged in
the beginning plummeted in terms of
trust at time two which was right after
that transgression and even though we
came back to you two days later to
apologize and recover your trust did not
recover relationship strength plummeted
Trust which is so hard to garner is
incredibly fast to kill so while you
promise trust just like in a marriage or
a best friendship once you lose that
trust it's extraordinarily difficult to
regain and so so many of these marketers
out there trying to promise trust don't
understand the perils they put
themselves in what was equally
interesting is the pattern with the
exciting brands now you started off
initially engaged just like this sincere
guy's dead
but you're you're the exciting brand oh
I'm so sorry I kind of explained this a
little differently but let me show you
what happened in the presence of the
transgression so the orange is the
sincere band in the transgression I
mentioned to you that you are Trust
plummeted and it do not recover but what
happened with the exciting brand in the
control condition over here in the green
your engagement and trust in the brand
naturally declined it was almost like it
was a fling like relationship but when I
we we had a transgression on the right
hand side you'll see the green yeah the
trust declined significantly but what
was interesting is that it increased
significantly when after two days later
we apologized and came back and we
restored the online photos so when I
promised excitement and you think it's
going to be a fun fling like brand and
something goes wrong you expect that
it's
quite exciting the ability to
renegotiate the contract to come through
to deliver more than what people expect
it actually puts you in a stronger
position so there's both the dark side
of trust as well as the upside of
excitement the corollary to that one is
being exciting is underrated interesting
interesting fighting number five cancer
can be rebranded so one of the one of
the research projects we do looks at the
conception of cancer which we show is as
as associated with being a bad thing not
only that but cancer is highly
associated with chemotherapy and the
action associated with chemotherapy so
chemo is oftentimes construed is also a
negative thing especially for young kids
who get cancer and what I've done with
some research at Hope lab which is
creates a DVD shoot-'em-up game called
remission is it allows kids to play a
shoot-'em-up game where they take on the
avatar Roxy and they cruise through the
body and they look for ugly cancer cells
and once they see that ugly cancer cells
they shoot them you know independent of
whether they're lurking in the pancreas
the stomach the colon and you have to
kill 100 percent of those ugly cancer
cells otherwise they'll self multiply
right before your very eyes
we show that one hour of playing
remission for these young kids versus a
control game we use Indiana Jones is
associated with higher levels of
adherence to treatment over all
subjective well-being which is
significantly higher and overall
survival rates that increase not only
that oh thank you I hope love is an
amazing amazing company I'm created by
Pam a majora of a major networks what's
also interesting is the reason it has
such a big impact on people's behavior
and overall survival is that it shifts
the affective associations of
chemotherapy through playing this game
people think that chemo something that I
own it's a good thing that's in my power
and I can kill cancer with it so it's
that effective association with chemo
which at a later point in time actually
makes cancer seem less scary
the final of the final interesting
finding number six is to engage others
be it for a cause or a nonprofit ask for
their time before you ask for their
money and what we show in this set of
findings here is if you tell people a
little bit about Hope lab and remission
in particular and then you put them in
three conditions so I'll say listen
you're so inspired by hope lab are you
interested in donating some time and
then we asked them about their money and
we put them you guys in a second
category so you flipped drawers for your
money first and you're in a control
condition you're not asked to anything
and we come back to you all one a
half-hour later and we say you know
would you like to actually give to Hope
lab you end up giving twice as much
money as this group and you're in the
middle so there's something happening
that's very important here where as
asking for money first makes you
disengage oftentimes it's another
nonprofit that's asking me for money
they're individuals that engage people
personally with their time often time
get people involved get them inspired
and it ends up part becoming part of
their own self it's a really important
and exciting finding independent of what
my father says so I'd like to close
through these last few minutes with a
few of my favorite Dave ocker isms as I
mentioned on the outside of this talk
he's had a dramatic impact on me and one
of the reasons is because of his author
isms one of his ocker isms which is
affected me deeply is Jennifer all you
have to do is get three hours of deep
hard thinking done each day and you know
in the beginning you're going like give
me a break you know like I'm you know
that's that's ridiculous I'm trying to
get a PhD here I need to work all of the
time but I took a little hint from him
and I actually asked a series of my
colleagues how many hours a deep part
thinking do you get done you today and
then I asked them how many hours of
depart thinking do you think you're
gonna get done each day and this was the
answer among the academics I asked they
got to and every day they went to bed
and got up the next morning and believed
that they were going to get
5.63
so that means these academics are going
to bed everyday feeling quite
discouraged instead you wake up and you
think just three hours and everything
that's icing and that has been one of
the key insights into sort of how we
live our life and and I and I did this
research survey with a bunch of my MBA
students as well and the date is not
nearly as depressing but it's up there a
few other Dave Walker algorithms that is
the worst sentence I've ever read let me
just tell you and when I started
producing research and I would give it
to him to read he would say he wouldn't
just say things he didn't write it and
you would spend time making it legible
which is a big step for him this is the
worst sentence I have ever read now you
probably thinking that's brutal
you know your ego must be this small you
know at this but I can't tell you how
refreshing it is to hear such brutal
honesty and when it comes like I don't
know there's something about him that
makes you like kind of giggle when he
says like no honestly that is the worst
thing I've ever heard so and you just
kind of laugh so it I would say that
there's a there's a great freedom that
comes from saying exactly what's on your
mind even if it's just truly brutal the
next one is I've never empirically
tested this but I have a strong
suspicion that if you buy people things
they will like you more and I have to
tell you I don't know if you need to run
that study but I think it works and for
those of you who have kids my dad to
this day it is amazing the bribes that
he gives his kids to hang out with him
our unbelievable and they work so well I
mean I'm definitely this is like number
one rule for raising my kids I've got a
bribe system that's instituted into
their childhood there are certain people
in life who when you interact with them
the only thing you should say to them is
man the weather is really good these
days
now let me unpack this a little bit when
I first came to Stanford there was one
individual who was just just torn yeah
in tears just all the time and I would
tell my dad and just one person everyone
else was fabulous just one person and my
dad would say like really you had
another conversation with him like
really let's let's practice hello
blink the weather has been wonderful
lately goodbye so if you make me you
make me work through this so all we need
is a short sentence to extricate
yourself and I think avoiding people
that annoy you or you dislike is an
incredible key to happiness and I have
data to back this up one of the most
important things to do when you start a
job carve out clear areas and confidence
and this is my dad is so incompetent in
so many dimensions it is incredibly
incredibly freeing he will purposely
break things and burn things in order to
earn the reputation of bad cleaner and
bad cook I got to tell you that I am a
horrible cleaner and a horrible cook and
it is all thanks to you all of my bad
qualities did a great job inspiring if
anyone likes more insights to the
importance of carving out clear ears and
confidence please email me I can't begin
to tell you the research that I've done
in with executives one small snippet one
of my best students by the way I always
asked my students you know what do you
remember about my class and without fail
they will say I didn't I really honestly
nothing like and they won't they are not
mean about it you know they say like I
liked you you know you were your
wonderful nice person you know but yeah
in terms of what I remembered for your
class nothing and as one student of mine
said you know I do remember that in
order to make us remember what a strong
brand was because this one as teaching
my brand planning which is not a brand
strategy class I said you know strong
brands clear carve out clear ears of
incompetence Lexus is not down-to-earth
old Navy does not make high-quality
clothing if you tear a piece of clothing
from Old Navy you do not care you know
you'll go back and buy another piece of
clothing if you're annoyed right and
that is so freeing and so I tried to
turn it
into people insights and I said listen
you should carve out clear eras of
incompetence in their life and I would
tell the dad story and so this one guy
who went off to McKinsey smartest guy
I've ever taught and he went into
McKenzie and the first day he was there
he said listen I'll do anything you like
but just am not so good with numbers
just saying I I'm you know I'm happy to
do him but I'm just not that good he was
promoted in McKinsey faster than any
other Stanford MBA because he had less
stuff to do right he was assigned less
stuff versus the other individual say I
could do anything bring it on and
thinking of all he was able to carve out
a focus in domains that he was actually
passionate about and we have a lot of
research to show that when you do work
that you're passionate about you have
more energy and you're more focused on
being productive the final of Dibakar
ISM a best response to a question is
that's a good question I wrote a book
that addresses that question have you
read my book it's it's it's a clencher
it's quite amazing and never have more
than eight words on a slide again just
proof that I sometimes don't listen to
him I like to close this with a final
quote which is one of my favorites Maya
Angelou is I've learned what the people
will forget what you said people will
forget what you did but people will
never forget about how you made them
feel and and that's my ode to my father
thank you for being her
we have probably time for one or two
questions if anyone has any yeah so that
sounds a very practical question I'll
turn that over to you well you know
there's a professor at Stanford no at
Berkeley named George Lee cough that
wrote a wonderful book is is there an
elephant or there's an elephant in the
room or something like that but he talks
about how skillful the Republican Party
is and there's probably 90% Republicans
in here I don't mean to disparage him
but they're they're so good at labeling
things you know like the death tax and
on and on and in it if you can if you
can frame the issue in such a way that
suddenly you're you you know you forward
the death tax then it's your sort of an
80 or 90% there and I think that you
know I was at a World Economic Forum
conference in Dubai last fall and there
was 70 councils around and they all were
generating proposals that that they
couldn't communicate very well and they
and they they really concluded they
needed brandied help to somehow you know
make the the these these proposals they
wanted to do more more understandable
and more acceptable and I don't know
about capitalism but I think the free
market system is definitely in a hole
and and they're gonna have to get out of
the hole by by doing some some kind of
substantive thing first and then there's
going to be a communication problem I
think you're right
it's a metaphor for for being something
that's self-contained so if you have it
it does come from the silos in the
agricultural world we have the corn in
one silo and wheat in another silo and
they're completely separate and they
don't interact and they don't
communicate so yeah that's where it
comes from yeah last question
another very practical question I would
the first thing I do is go at an expert
on cross-cultural consumer behavior but
it is the case that you there was a
famous paper by Ted Levitt of Harvard
about 20 years ago that suggested that
you should standardize marketing across
countries but most people and there was
a flurry of activity along that
direction for about 10 years but most
people realize now that you know if if
the cultures are different you can't in
or the context are different you can't
for sameness and you have to adjust and
so you and one way to adjust of course
is to have all these countries do their
own thing but a better way to adjust is
to have a common brand and a common
marketing program and adapt it to the
different countries but you you know the
way that that framework that I showed
you those five families of traits is one
sort of lens you can use to think about
local creation of goods or one way to
think about how you could blend the
global and local strategy so for example
exciting brands pretty much every
country that we've surveyed at least you
know which is over about fifteen value
excitement but the meaning of excitement
has nuanced differences so for example
an excitement in America really means
this exciting cool hip energetic young
imaginative set of traits and in Japan
exciting means or tends to mean exciting
silly funny cute likeable friendly
almost hello kitty ish or something you
know it's it has a very different
connotation so you can position globally
around this notion of excitement and
indeed positioning around personality
dimensions tends to be highly useful
both tactically and strategically but
then you dial up the the local
importance of that so if you're a small
mom-and-pop shop in Japan
or starting a small business
understanding that difference and then
beings were true to what you're creating
it tends to be more useful strategy than
anything that's more globalized okay
well there's one or two more do we have
time for one okay two more over there
and they're good yeah this is the
dueling professors part you're trying
yeah I see where you're going all right
so I will take my first whack at this
this this I I would say that he's wrong
I I would say why not I I why I could I
don't need any data to say that I can
just say that yeah I know yeah like you
probably thought he was right I I think
that um I think that energy is very
important I think it has to do with
momentum and trajectory are you making
money are you moving forward are you
doing positive things for the world I
think that that feeling that there is a
company that's on an upward trajectory
which I think Dad will concur with is
extremely important at the base of it
though I think also consumers
fundamentally need to trust that trust
that company and Trust comes through
sincerity and being authentic and what
we're seeing right now in the financial
downturn and even what red cross has
done against the tsunami and Katrina etc
is has not done a great job of
establishing trust and I think what
social networking and social media does
right now is provide a platform for us
to poke holes and promises of trust and
potential areas of democracy so the new
companies that are coming out that are
doing so an authentic way and remember
Trust is not about perfection you can be
energizing but do so in an authentic way
that cultivates trust so I think that's
really that the the right way to think
about it my dimensions are orthogonal
that means that they're created to be
coexisting so if you think about sincere
trust or authenticity
then you think about this notion of
energizing if I think that there's a
real sweet spot in that right-hand
quadrant see I reconciled it all if I
just talk long enough
I will reconcile it Jennifer's wrong
yeah there's a book called the brand
bubble which analyzes the why in our
database which is like 15 years of data
were they track were they every couple
years did a survey that involved
thousands of brands hundred hundred
countries eighty-four majors on each
brand including most of Jennifer's
personality scale and and they've and
what they've observed is in the last
eight years
trust overall has gone down like 40
percent the the average trust associated
with the brands going on 40 percent
that's consistent with what I just said
just saying and the and other kinds of
majors liking has gone down it's it's
really and one of their point is there's
a brand bubble and that brands are over
evaluated but in the financial community
because they've deteriorated so but the
exceptions are those brands that have
energy those the brand set of energy are
driving stock return they're driving ROI
they're not declining and and so on and
so they've concluded that their prior
position they used to have four
dimensions of a brand visibility
relevance differentiation and what this
team and and they say now that that in
before they said differentiation
relevance were the most important part
of success you had a visibility I'd have
esteem but it was really differentiation
relevance and now they say that that
energy is more important than either of
those and so yeah so dad's wrong but uh
no I'm just kidding um so we could this
is actually a very rich topic but I
would I would refer you to the Young &
Rubicam database which is called brand
asset valuation study and what you need
to do is look into the actual brands
that have those energies that are that
are energy that are going on the upswing
but also start to look at which of those
brands there are so Google for example
is one of them and I think that at some
level they've had
some trust issues but they're very minor
and they've kept it relatively contained
relative to for example with Microsoft
in the 1980s and so that trust is
bundled into those few brands that are
reversing traduction that one more
question I know that there's a lot of
questions but I'm also hesitant to go
too much over our time so we will be up
here for a little while over the time
yet
really yeah we started at a quarter of
okay we'll take one more question and
then we'll be up here all those examples
are interesting I mean the the father's
most mobility example that my opinion
the biggest mistake that General Motors
ever made which is a huge statement is
that they they put money into automobile
instead of Saturn they had a duel in
Saturn and they and they gave Oldsmobile
the money and it was such a sick brand
they had to call it their fathers those
'mobile because nobody would buy the
thing I mean when they came out with
their their new car in the mid 90s if
they if they took the label the
automobile label off it the acceptance
of the brand went up dramatically so
they tried to sort of hide Oz 'mobile in
and if they would have given that Brant
that car to Saturn it would have been a
whole different company in my opinion
but so that's the Oldsmobile what was
the other Datsun and Nissan Oh Datsun
the Nissan yeah that know what Datsun
Nissan that's another incredible thing
you know they spent two hundred million
dollars
we're under with the campaign saying the
name is Nissan that was that for two
years they said the name is decent for
two hundred million dollars
which was
a lot of money in those days and in five
years later Datsun was still as strong a
brand as Nissan I mean I mean they
thought you know it was a big Eagle
thing I mean they would be over in in in
these executives and Nissan would be in
a hotel and nobody had heard of Nissan
and they didn't like that so they wanted
it was yeah it was really it was absurd
it was it was not a good decision so I
so in that case it was an ego thing that
that the Nissan people just wanted to be
recognized when they went in a hotel I'm
not kidding
what's that yeah well there is like five
different people so I'm one option is
just for us to hang out up here and take
your questions so if you have questions
we'll